dès sa jeunesse le général de Gaulle à
lui aussi portait un regard critique sur
le régime parlementaire un parlement qui
selon lui parle trop et n'agit pas assez
lorsqu'on débouche sur la guerre de 1914
le capitaine de Gaulle qui combat estime
que le régime parlementaire et tout à
fait incapable de conduire la guerre
alors on connaît une lettre qu'il a
adressée à sa mère en 1915 où il dit
tout le mal qu'il pense du régime
parlementaire
le Parlement devient de plus en plus
odieux et bête les ministres ont
littéralement toute leur journée prises
par les séances de la Chambre du Sénat
ou la lecture des injonctions les plus
saugrenues du premier marchand de vins
venus que la politique a changé en
député
nous serons vainqueurs dès que nous
aurons balayé cette racaille
depuis le secrétariat général de la
Défense nationale où il a été nommé en
1931 le général de Gaulle observe de
près l'impuissance du système politique
de la Troisième République il y a
d'ailleurs une anecdote fameuse ou le
général de Gaulle reçu par le président
du Conseil Léon Blum au moment du Front
populaire voit sa conversation
interrompue à plusieurs reprises par des
coups de fil qui viennent de la Chambre
des députés et qui oblige véritablement
le président du Conseil l'homme du
pouvoir exécutif finalement à se plier
au péripéties de la chose parlementaire
et c'est là que le général de Gaulle
comprend que ce système parlementaire
est un système impuissant qui n'arrive
pas à résoudre les problèmes parce qu'il
est trop long parce que il empêche celui
qui exécute d'avoir le pouvoir
nécessaire pour imposer sa décision
à la même époque le général de Gaulle
publie une série d'ouvrages le fil de
l'épée en 1932 vers l'armée de métiers
en 1934 la France et son armée en 1938
il y expose notamment ses idées sur
l'autorité militaire et sur l'art de
commander dans le premier il écrit les
hommes ne se passent point au fond
d'être dirigé non plus que de manger
boire et dormir ces animaux politiques
ont besoin d'organisation c'est-à-dire
d'ordre et de chefs et au fond c'est
parce qu'il est un militaire d'abord un
militaire qu'il comprend la nécessité et
la force du commandement qu'il veut
transposer ce tropisme du commandement
vers le monde politique vers la fonction
présidentielle c'est-à-dire un président
de la République qui sera le général en
chef un Premier ministre qui serait
chargé de l'exécution comme chef
d'état-major général et puis des
généraux dans les ministères dont chacun
en fait à gérer son corps d'armée de
fonctionnaires et les problèmes qui sont
afférents à partir de 1940 le Général de
Gaulle joue un rôle majeur en tant que
chef de la résistance il constitue en
Comité français de libération nationale
puis en gouvernement provisoire de la
République française
à la Libération celui qui apparaît comme
le vainqueur de la guerre et
profondément opposé au projet de
l'Assemblée chargée de rédiger la
nouvelle constitution de la Quatrième
République c'est pourquoi une
démissionne le 20 janvier 1946 de la
présidence du gouvernement et seront à
Bayeux 5 mois plus tard le 16 juin pour
exprimer son désaccord et exposer ses
idées
le chef de l'État la fonction de
promulguer les lois et de prendre les
décrets parce que ces vis-à-vis de
l'État tout entier que ceux-ci comme
celle-là engage les citoyens
le discours de Bayeux c'est d'abord une
rupture avec ce projet de Constitution
et élaboré par les assemblées
parlementaires
cette dénonciation du régime des parties
c'est l'idée que on n'a pas construit un
président de la République guide de la
nation arbitre de l'intérêt national
mais en inaugureur de plaisanthème comme
De Gaulle l'appellera que le pouvoir
de l'État et dans les mains du Parlement
des partis politiques des combinaisons
et donc il n'y aura pas de pouvoir
gouvernemental autrement dit ce qui est
esquissé à Bayeux c'est une synthèse
entre les deux traditions politiques que
connaît la France depuis la Révolution
la tradition parlementaires qui a marqué
les différentes républiques et la
tradition autoritaire efficace qui a
marqué les deux empires pour manifester
son hostilité au régime des parties le
14 avril 1945 de Gaulle des signes de
créer son propre mouvement politique le
Rassemblement du peuple français il
s'agit
ce sentiment trouvé un cadre
dans lequel il puisse s'exprimer et qui
lui permettent de devenir une force
susceptible de créer une atmosphère et
d'appuyer une politique déterminée elle
a surprise générale les candidats
gaullistes comportent haut la main les
élections municipales d'octobre de la
même année ces partisans se demandent
alors si le général de Gaulle ne
pourrait pas revenir au pouvoir mais le
RPF après un démarrage extrêmement
positif c'était soufflé le général a dit
à son entourage on arrête je n'arriverai
pas à reprendre le pouvoir il va
commencer ce que l'on a appelé une
traversée du désert c'est à dire qu'il
ne joue plus de rôle politique
inacceptent pas ces institutions il
n'accepte pas ce jeu est parti politique
et l'attend
et en attendant il nourrit la réflexion